foreign
hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning iot full course but before
we begin let me tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you're a tech geek in
a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn now without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's session
first we will begin with a quick crash
course on iot where we will learn what
exactly is iot and the fundamental
concepts of internet of things followed
by the crash course on iot we will learn
what is arduino once we understand what
exactly is arduino we will dive into the
raspberry pi once we are done with the
fundamentals and technical concepts of
arduino and raspberry pi we will discuss
the critical differences between the
both
so once having a better understanding of
what are raspberry pi and arduino and
their critical differences between each
of them we will try to develop some
projects based on both arduino and
raspberry pi once we have the best
understanding of arduino and raspberry
pi we will dive deep into raspberry pi
zero once we are done with the raspberry
pi zero we will dive into the latest
version of raspberry pi that is
raspberry pi 4. so these are the agenda
pointers that we will be discussing
today hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now over to our training experts
until recently access to the internet
was limited by our devices like the
desktop tablet or smartphone
but now with the internet of things aka
iot practically all appliances can be
connected to the internet and monitored
remotely
it is a system of interconnected devices
that transfer data
over a wireless network without any
human intervention
so hey everyone in this video we help
you understand what iot is and how it is
impacting our day-to-day life
we will also understand the iot
architecture and look at the new
trending iot projects for 2021
but before that if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
i'm sure you're excited to learn so
let's
dive
[Music]
to know the status of your ac
wouldn't that be amazing
yes
and this can be achieved with the help
of the internet of things
until recently is limited via devices
like the desktop tablet or smartphone
but now
iot practically appliances can be
connected to the internet and monitored
remotely iot is shaping the way we live
our lives it helps us get a better
insight into the working of things
around us
so what exactly is the internet of this
iot is a system of interrelated devices
transfer and receive data from one to
the other a smart home is the best
example of iot
instead the ac
doorbell thermostats smoke detectors
water heaters and security alarms can be
interconnected to share data with the
user
over a mobile looking of the devices
around him
think about it until recently internet
helped people connect and interact with
each other but now inanimate objects or
things have the ability to sense the
surroundings to interact and collaborate
with one another
for example
in the morning when your alarm goes off
the iot system can open the window
blinds turn on the coffee pot for you
and even turn on the water heater
although all of this is fascinating
there's a lot that goes on in the
background to ensure seamless
functioning from effective communication
between devices to accurate processing
of the data received a lot of components
are involved
in the context of iot devices hardware
can be classified into general devices
and sensing devices the general devices
are the main components of the data hub
and information exchange
they are connected either by wired or
wireless interfaces
home appliances are a classic example of
such devices
the sensing devices on the other hand
include sensors and actuators
they measure the temperature humidity
light intensity and other parameters
devices are connected to the network
with the help of gateways
these gateways or processing nodes
process the information collected from
the sensors and transfer it to the cloud
the cloud acts as both the storage and
processing unit actions are performed on
the collected data for further learning
and inferences
wired and wireless interfaces like wi-fi
bluetooth z gsms and so on are used to
provide connectivity to ensure its
ubiquity applications need to support a
diverse set of devices and communication
protocols from tiny sensors capable of
sensing and reporting the desired factor
to powerful back-end servers that are
utilized for data analysis and knowledge
extraction
to help you understand it's working
let's take a simple scenario
let's suppose you want to water your
garden every time the moisture level in
the soil drops
instead of doing it manually you could
automate it using iot
the sensors and actuators installed
gauge the soil for its moisture this
information is sent to the iot gateway
with the help of communication protocols
like mqtt or http the gateway
significantly aggregates data and feeds
it to the cloud with the help of wi-fi
land
once the moisture level drops the system
is immediately triggered and the
sprinklers are turned on however with
the information stored in the cloud a
detailed analysis like the time of the
day the sprinkler was turned on the rate
at which the moisture in the soil
reduces and so on can be done and the
report could be sent over to you on your
smartphone over an app
with the improved response monitoring
and analytical capabilities iot is being
adopted in almost all industries and
domains opening doors to endless
applications
today iot is being used extensively to
lessen the burden on humans to name a
few iot is deployed for smart homes
wearables watches and bracelets smart
cars
smart farming smart retail smart grids
smart city and smart health care
with such a wide spectrum of
applications the future of it looks more
promising than ever before
in 2018 there were about 23 billion
connected devices which was more than
double the world population
according to experts there will be over
80 billion devices by 2025. iot is a
vision to connect all devices
with the power internet always learning
and always scrolling
iots here's a simple question for you
which of the following